on the substance the great barrington
declaration is underpinned by two
central claims and both are emphatically
false first it says that if enough
people get covered we will reach
herd immunity this is not true
many infectious diseases never reach
herd immunity like measles and malaria
and aids and flu
and with increasing evidence of
re-infection
we should have no confidence that we
would ever reach herd immunity to covid
even if everyone caught it herd immunity
is a flawed goal without a vaccine
even if we could get to it which we
can't
the second central claim is that we can
segregate the old
and the vulnerable on our way to herd
immunity this is simply
not possible as the medical director of
the nhs said yesterday
we cannot somehow fence off the elderly
and the vulnerable from risk
while everyone else returns to normal
it's neither conscionable
nor practicable not when so many people
live in intergenerational homes
when older people need carers who of
course themselves live in the community
and not when young people can suffer the
debilitating impact of long covert
whenever we've seen cases among young
people rise sharply
we then see cases among the over 60s
rise
inevitably thereafter and we are not the
kind of country that abandons our
vulnerable
or just locks them up if we let this
virus continue
unchecked the loss of life would be
simply too great to contemplate
and we know it would put our nhs at risk
as my honorable friends have just said
both we know this both because of what
happened in march and because of what is
happening
right now we've already heard from the
heads of the academy of royal colleges
and the royal college of emergency
medicine that if we don't act
fast and come together to quash this
virus then we risk putting the nhs under
extraordinary
strain both for covid treatments and
no non-covered treatments too and of
course i'll give away to my right
honourable friend
my right honourable friend how long do
the scientists think we will need these
lockdowns for and what's their
exit plan well we have seen the exit
plan
from local lockdowns for instance in
leicester where we had a firm local
lockdown the case rate came right down
we lifted that and we have sadly seen it
start to rise again so it is determined
by
uh the amount of social mixing that
the the lockdown reduces um and so there
is an argument that in some of the parts
of the country where the
case rate has continued to rise there is
an argument
for further ensuring that you don't get
the contact
that is that is at the root of the
virus spreading and that is the
challenge is how to calibrate the
lockdown to get the virus under control
whilst doing the minimum damage to the
economy and to
education